et on prend tout de suite la direction
de château renault je vous disais en
titre en milieu d'après-midi une femme a
dû être secouru blessé par balle
immédiatement les forces de l'ordre se
sont rendues sur place pour boucler le
secteur collèges et écoles ont été
évacués on retrouve en direct nos
journalistes paul boyer samuel colin
paul ii quelles infos dispose-t-on à
l'heure actuelle alors oui effectivement
audrey je me trouve en plein centre
ville de château renault à quelques
dizaines de mètres en fait de
l'appartement où l'homme a ouvert le feu
depuis sa fenêtre aux alentours de 16
heures cet après-midi selon les
gendarmes
il s'agirait d'un seul tir l'homme a
blessé une adolescente de 17 ans à la
cuisse elle a immédiatement été
transportée au chu de trousseau son
pronostic vital n'est pas encore engagé
paul de quels moyens de secours et
surtout de gendarmes du gign sont sur
place est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
sur place
alors oui audrey ya beaucoup de gens sur
place mais pour le moment ce que l'on
sait c'est que juste après l'impact
la jeune fille a réussi dans sa chute à
identifier la fenêtre où se trouvait le
tireur suite à cela
ça a permis aux forces de l'ordre
gendarmes et policiers de rapidement se
déployer et comme vous pouvez le voir
juste derrière moi tout le secteur est
encore bouclé une équipe du gign déployé
deux tours est également sur place
depuis maintenant plus d'une heure nous
ne savons en revanche pas quand l'assaut
des buts rhin ce que je peux vous dire
maintenant c'est qu'ici le climat est
très étrange dans les rues par un chat
volets fermés
quelques voitures de curieux comme vous
pouvez le voir juste derrière moi
viennent voir le lieu mais impossible
d'accéder plus loin que l'endroit où je
me situe enfin nous avons réussi à
contacter la maire de la ville en fin
d'après midi elle a rapidement pris les
mesures nécessaires concernant les
sorties d'école afin que les élèves
puissent retourner sains et saufs à leur
domicile
merci beaucoup paul pour toutes ces
précisions et attention à vous quand
même à château renault est donc une
conférence de presse devrait avoir lieu
dans quelques instants présence de la
maire de château renault